so Lego yeah what's what's that up about
what's up with that Joe what's up with
that look as a kid I'm sure everyone had
that like you know Lego bucket Lego
collection as did I you know I loved
playing with Legos as a kid and then
when I got older I realized oh there are
Lego boxes for adults like like massive
Lego collections for adult all leg Legos
well you know I think there's most Legos
are for every age and there are some are
more cater towards kids more C towards
kids and then there are ones where it's
just like like there's a couple of boxes
that I bought which are like straight up
just say 18 plus and I was just like oh
okay what are you building titties yeah
that's what I thought I'm like it's a
bit of a weird like way to advertise it
but like yeah um cuz like you know
growing up I loved like building Legos
and like did you guys ever have like
these things called meos yeah yeah like
it's basically like it's like Lego
except they're metallic pieces and you
use like nuts and bolts and screws to
like put everything together gears and
gears and like you can add Electronics
to it and stuff like that it's basically
like Hasbro is my first robotic I watch
that guy on YouTube who builds Lego
machines oh yeah he he's like how many
gears can I add to this system and then
he just or he's like I'm going to make
an underwater car of Lego and you're
like okay that's that's sick yeah just
[__] like that so it's like uh and Japan
as well has like a bunch of Lego stores
all over and there's one kind of near my
house and like I I would go into it
every now and then just to be like oh I
wonder what like how Lego has evolved
and then I went in and I saw like a
bunch of like really [__] sick Lego
pieces that I was just like you know
what I'm going to go back to my
childhood and just like build a bunch of
Legos just to see what it's like and
it's been it's it's I've kind of used it
as my form of meditation this year of
just like just playing some music or
like putting on a show on TV and just
like sitting down and just building a
Lego do anything but watch
anime I mean to be fair I did watch I
watch H Paradise while building
Lego okay so give me your what were your
top three Lego sets top three Lego sets
okay so the one I recently finished was
um you know the Giant Wave painting by
katus Hawai like Japanese P one gave
this one away in my Charity Auction yeah
yeah yeah so it's that like the Lego set
of that uh and it's kind of like this
like really cool it creates this really
cool 3D Lego painting and you can like
actually they built it so that you can
actually hang it up on the wall so we
have it hung up on our on our wall and
it actually looks kind of dope the
coolest one by far though is I built a
fully functioning Pac-Man arcade machine
out of Legos oh that's
sick and I'll I'll I'll send a video to
M as well to put in the episode but
basically you can build this it's it's
probably it stands about this tall um
and it's just fully operating I say
fully operating but like there's a lot
of moving parts to it but like instead
of accidentally playing on the arcade
like with the joystick and whatever
there's a crank on the side and it and
the actual screen you can actually move
around the Pac-Man and all of the yeah
this thing so I built this oh sick and
the top part uh has like the Pac-Man
logo which you can like press a button
and it flips around wait so is it like
an actual screen in a game uh no no so
all of this is like built out of Legos
what can I see a video can we go on a
video I want to see how this works and
so basically it it's me to look like a
screen but what it is is that it's these
individual like Pac-Man Lego pieces that
are on a little chain I had no idea that
Lego went this intri they're going ham
have they already stopped selling this
cuz I already saw resale prices for like
500 bucks uh I don't know actually but
yeah this is the exact one I [__] and a
bought uh bought this for me for my
birthday and can you skip ahead see
where he's play so that little crank on
the side there you can crank it and all
of the inside like pieces like the
Pacman's and the ghosts they kind of
move around on a chain does what and you
build all of that from scratch this I
think this took me about two full days
to make that's insane yeah ahead when
he's playing with it yeah yeah so you
can like press buttons lights turn on uh
you can move the joy sticks around stuff
like
that um yeah so like those individual
like pellets and stuff like that you
have to punch them all in and then by
spinning the thing it moves the pieces
around to make it look like it's
actually like moving and functioning so
it doesn't actually obviously it can't
like actually play a game but it can oh
yeah so go to the most replay part there
yeah so it's like that wait that's
actually sick wait that's so sick yeah
right it's [__] cool wait can he but
he can't get the pallets right no no no
so so you have to attach them to the
chains it just and there but that way
that's so sick though the fact that it
even like can like emulate yeah right
the only thing that stressed me out
about Lego and I'm sure you might have
been dealing with this conundrum is uh
where the [__] do I put all this [__]
when I'm done cuz like you run out of
room fast with Lego cuz Lego's
big need to have like a room dedicated
to just Lego yeah I've just I've just
kind of put this is why every guy needs
a like a man closet you
know Jaan does not allow the man cave I
know it doesn't
don't we don't live in rural Ohio G
where I have 15 spare rooms okay that's
why when you [__] reach your 40s or
whatever you go into like the
countryside and you get a basement where
you build just you like a basement where
you just build [__] and it's just where
it's it's the it's the place where [__]
just accumulates right so all of my Lego
stuff I put on the same shelf as all my
gun
pla so it's just like I have a
dedicated I I have a dedicated shelf of
like this is the [__] I made yeah uh so
that's pretty cool I you know I love gum
but I think the one thing that Lego has
just done amazingly is not requiring
tools like you build so many things
without tools or if they you know if you
do need tools it's yeah my my biggest
problem with gunpla is you need a
[__] [__] like John Wick tool kit
you got to wrap out and you don't
necessarily need to all you really need
is a pair ofpp I but you know if you
want to go like full like you got to get
like the paint out you got to get the
[__] fiddly fiddly little stick you
got to get the Sandpaper as well the
Sandpaper as well and that is just way
too much craftsmanship for me like the
cool thing is is that like uh you know
with the hawy painting I made uh because
that is like pretty just looks nice and
you can put it on the wall we've like
started dedicating a little area of our
house to like kind of turn into like a
like an old Japanese style thing so
another one I built it's not a Lego
necessarily it's like Nano blocks which
is like a smaller version of Legos but I
built a bonsai out of that so so I just
placed the Bonsai next to the painting
and it just looks nice it like actually
matches the theme and there's another
one where it's like a full Japanese
garden which o really wants me to make
to like match that be the Lego guy I
already am like man but yeah like it
just made me realize like yeah I [__]
miss just like you know mindlessly just
like making some cool [__] and like
again it's been like a great way to just
kind of like turn off from everything
and just like meditate almost uh so yeah
if you're an adult yeah go get some
Legos it's uh it's it's good fun um
let's see what else do we have I mean
obviously L top left uh tears of the
Kingdom I think we talked about that on
an episode did we I think I did I don't
know but did you enjoy it that much I
played the [__] out of this game bro I I
don't know if this is a hot take I think
it's better than breath of the well I
think it looked again I've played like
one hour of this game yeah I felt like I
booted it up and I was like oh [__] it's
just [__] breath of the wild right
when you start off for sure yeah because
it the exact same map yeah and then it's
like uh they had the banjo kazes thing
banjo Kaz nuts and bols oh well you
build your own
[__] Lego again it's just Lego yeah
that's just Joey went from playing Lego
in real life to Lego virtually I don't
know I kind of I kind of was really
excited for them to kind of hopefully go
in a bit of a different direction almost
I think they did though because what I
thought was kind of Genius was the fact
that yes the the main map of highroll is
pretty much exactly the same as birth of
the wild yeah uh but with because they
add completely new power Ops now the way
Traverse
famely new to and also with the islands
like a whole new area and also the full
underground as well do you want to know
what put me off into playing this
already it's the underground section man
why I don't know it just I you know
sometimes you look at a video game and
there are some levels that you really
Vibe with and really like and then
sometimes you just get through a level
even though you [__] hated it that's
just me with Underground Level and Cave
levels you know you love cave levels I
[__] I hate it man it's so rare you
can get you can make like Gamers lose
any sense of direction caves are so I
hate that so much that's that's like you
can't get that anywhere else right like
and I don't want to go [__] caving in
real life but of the Kingdom did that to
the tea as well because when you go into
the underground first it is Pitch Black
oh my God that that's everything I hate
so you just have to like blindly
traversed like you know when you're
you're like you're like 11 11 years old
and you're like I can get through this
Pokemon without Flash yeah and then you
start like the biggest mistake of your
life and it's terrifying cuz you're like
I might not ever get out of here like I
I I love trying to recreate that feeling
cuz you'll never get that feeling ever
again that Zoom when you realiz too
smart you're too smart you know that
you're not going to get that Doom when
you realize you have no Escape ropes
just like well I guess I'm here forever
now caving to me is caving to me in a
video game is just anxiety simulator and
I [__] hate that oh my God I prefer
that because I rather experience that
anxiety in a video game where there are
no Stakes as opposed to real life you
know let me tell let me tell you why let
me tell you why I hate cave levels in
every video game the completion is in me
it's just like okay I'm going to
systematically explore everything in
this cave you take like five steps
you're like okay here's a wall I've
explored this area you turn around
you're like wait this isn't where I
started off and then you get completely
lost so that little side of me that is
that it says like I want to I want to
complet explore this area I just get
completely lost and I can't
systematically explore the way I like to
explore levels okay then you might like
the way that tear of the kingdom does
then because in tear of the Kingdom
there are like several holes in the main
world where you can like jump into to
access different parts of the
underground and at first when you jump
in it's like you look at the map and
it's just completely pitch black but the
way that the game kind of forces you to
like navigate and explore it is that
like kind of like with shrines in breath
of the wild you see something in the
distance and you go oh that's a place
that I can just head towards and the and
and the underground kind of does the
same thing it's not quite shrines it's
like some other thing but when you get
to it it lights up a certain area
surrounding that checkpoint and so
gradually you open up more of the map of
the underground so it's a really
ingenious way of like you know giving
you that sense of dread that Conor was
saying but also giving you like a
motivation to step into that dread and I
think that's like one thing that breath
of the wild didn't quite have because
breath of the wild is like kind of you
go to a tower and then immediately
everything is opened up and then it's
just you know right for the yeah
Assassin's Creed style right but the
underground I thought was like an
interesting addition to that because it
it's a lot harder than the main did you
enjoy it did you enjoy the underground
section I did actually I I fully
completed the map as well because it
actually motivated me to like I want to
see what this entire place looks like
yeah I think the the the problem I'm
having this year with gaming is that
even though
I'm you know very fortunate and I can
stream games fulltime I still don't have
enough time to play all the games I want
to play yeah M and like you look at like
some of the best games this of this year
a lot of them are [__] long games
breath of wild is an 80 hour Game Y uh
bers Gate 3 as well is like hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of hours and it's
like I I recognize that Zelda Tu of the
kingdom is probably another absolute
Banger they've knocked out of the park
but I was you know when I when I I
bought the game I booted it up for hour
and I was like you know what these 80
hours even though people be like oh he
plays [__] sua game or he plays
[__] jump King it's like yeah but
like I only lose like 10 hours from
doing that or like you know 10 hours
here and there and it's like I think for
me personally I didn't want to kind of
experience a very similar experience to
breath of the wild but maybe with a
Different Twist on it I'd felt like I'd
kind of got my feel of that and that
world and I was kind of hoping sorry SP
everywhere it's kind of hoping for me I
wanted like an kind of a different
experience and and when I was looking at
the building mechanics in the new world
I was like it doesn't really feel like
enough for me to want to get reinvested
sink at least 80 hours into this world
and do it all over again yeah I was like
I'd rather just spend my time gaming on
other stuff this year that's fair and so
but then if you say that people like oh
you to [__] play Zelda you you're not
a real gamer and it's like well you know
you
okay congrats you no gamer congrats you
wanted to [__] play I mean you're
arguing with that you can't win against
you know no I I mean listen Zelda fans
are Zelda fans and they it's like it's
like you know just it's like telling
wine snobs you're like you know maybe I
don't want to spend $300 on a wine like
what do you mean it's the best fanciest
wine of all everyone agrees it's the
best it's like well it's just not for me
maybe I just don't want this again chill
the [__] out you know solo game that
came out this year that's short of [__]
like 10 hours [__] the new Super
Mario RPG remake dude I want to play
that that game is short as hell I I beat
it in a day everyone everyone is
complimenting it for being a a 10 12h
hour game everyone's like thank [__]
God I RPG game where you cut out all the
[__] yeah I feel like we need more
of that if anything we need more I
actually forgot how short it was when I
beat it I was like oh yeah the original
is also this length it just felt longer
because I was a dumb child and I
couldn't go through the game as quickly
as I can now but yeah it's a [__]
awesome game like I was debating between
putting that there instead of uh breath
of the wild but they're both you you
should play that you could easily I
really really want to do that uh because
I've heard nothing but good things and
again the the main thing I've heard
about it is that it cuts out all the
grinding and all the dumb [__] yep you
literally don't have to grind yeah which
is like I I think I there should be an
option where I never have to do a side
quest or grind in an RPG I I firmly
believe that well like you don't have to
do a side quest no I know but like I I
shouldn't have to like also you don't
have to grind if you're gamer
enough okay first of all some some RPGs
will just straight up be like you do not
you are nowhere near leveled up for this
you're like but I've done every Mission
up until this point yeah but those RPGs
are usually ass anyway yeah those are
nor those are normally like the older
RPGs now if anything I feel like RPGs
modern day uh have gotten better in not
making sure you have to grind but the
annoying part is just the natural
getting from point A to point B you are
just going to natur yeah I feel I feel
modern jrpgs now they put grinding in as
an option for people who can't out
strategize the game like normally W no
they can like legit like you know like
there's a lot of uh games like smaller
jrpgs that I played this year that were
quite new and I realized that like I was
getting through these games a lot faster
not because they're any easier but
because they made it easier for you to
figure out strategically how you can get
past these difficult points whereas the
older jrpgs your only option was to just
be at a higher level because there were
less options I have a question
completely unrelated to RPGs um Persona
does persona have grinding
Persona why is it so godamn long it's
like 200 long right because the story is
long yeah they need to chill the [__]
out Persona 3 remake next year [__]
let's go I'm so excited let's go yeah
Persona is kind it's it's almost you're
going to hate this it's almost like a
vision over at some points so many
different mechanics but it's you know
it's present the story's presented you
to you in like kind of a visual novel
form esque it's cuz you know whenever I
watch memes or videos about persona it's
like it looks so [__] hype it's so
fun all the menuing and it's so cool and
whenever watch streams I'd go in it'd be
[__] resident sleeper dude I'd go in
there it's [__] guy clicking a for 15
hours and I'm like happened something
happen stop [__] trying to [__] the
teacher I mean it does happen it's just
to from from the from point A to point B
is just a long talk more about it later
Persona is almost like five different
games in one okay okay uh so breath of
wild not breath of wild breath of the
boring as Pete calls it bre